100 des classes et des écoles qui
ferment qui veut ça madame la ministre
la parole est à monsieur eric ciotti
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
vendredi prochain la nation rendra
hommage aux victimes de l'attentât de
nice entre le 7 janvier 2015 et ce
funeste 14 juillet 2016
242 nos concitoyens ont été fauchés par
la barbarie islamiste ministre de
l'intérieur appelait tout à l'heure le
la menace combien la menace s'était
toujours permanente et combien elle
était grave c'est dans ce contexte que
le président de la république a indiqué
pourtant et ce n'était pas dans un livre
que notre arsenal pénal pour lutter
contre le terrorisme était complet ce
n'est pas notre analyse ce n'est pas
notre possible notre position nous
considérons nous face à cette forme de
fatalité impuissante que face au
terrorisme non on n'a pas tout essayé
c'est pour cela que demain matin le
groupe des républicains et son président
christian jacob défendront une
proposition de loi complète exhaustive
pour marquer une approche différente
dans la lutte contre le terrorisme avec
des mesures très pragmatique avec des
mesures qui s'inspirent d'un principe de
précaution
éviter que ceux qui sont identifiés
comme dangereux pour la société ne passe
à l'acte intervenir avant et ne pas
intervenir après c'est pour cela que
nous proposerons la rétention
administrative sous le contrôle du juge
c'est pour cela que nous proposerons la
rétention de sûreté pour éviter que des
personnes très dangereuse ne sortent de
prison et constitue une menace très
forte c'est pour cela que nous
demanderons l'expulsion de tous les
étrangers condamnés pour actes de
terrorisme ou en relation avec une
entreprise terroriste
c'est pour cela que nous demanderons que
soit mis enfin en place une véritable
légitime défense pour les policiers
nous vous demandons quelle position
monsieur le premier ministre vous
adopterez vous soutenir ces pays s'il
apparaît comme monsieur jean jacques
urvoas
garde des sceaux ministre de la justice
sur le président monsieur le député eric
ciotti l'assemblée nationale connaît
votre persévérance y compris dans
l'erreur
puisque cela fait maintenant
cela cela fait maintenant quatre ans que
vous nourrissez les débats
parlementaires avec des propositions de
lois qui sont tout aussi original qu'un
praticable parce que si je devais
résumer le texte que nous allons étudier
demain et naturellement nous aurons
comme à chaque fois un débat au fond
dans le respect des positions des uns et
des autres qu'est ce que vous nous
proposez soit des éléments qui existent
déjà par exemple la capacité d'expulsion
alors que vous savez parfaitement
monsieur le député que ce gouvernement
expulse comme personne n'a jamais jamais
expulsé puisque depuis 2012 nous avons
expulsé 86 personnes étranges et
radicaliser pour menaces alors il vous
plaît donc et aux thèses 16 depuis le
début de l'année je ne vous ferai pas
l'affront de vous proposer les chiffres
en comparaison dans la législature
précédente
de la même manière vous nous proposez
des mesures que vous présentez comme
étant pragmatique en nous disant qu'il
faut pratiquer la rétention des fichiers
est ce monsieur le député vous ne nous
dit jamais où vous allez les incarcérer
qui va les garder ils sont dix milles
sur les fichiers s demain matin vous
mettez dix mille personnes en prison ou
voulait fait gardé par qui voulaient
fait garder pendant combien de temps
vous voulez être pratique alors soyez
pratique jusqu'au bout c'est évidemment
inapplicable et vous le savez parce que
non seulement le conseil d'état vous l'a
déjà dit mais la convention européenne
des droits de l'homme nous l'interdît
troisième élément nous proposer des
éléments qui sont des éléments de
complexion de complexification par
contre du droit je crains qu'avec cette
volonté de toujours imaginer des
positions qui sont aussi original qu'un
praticable vous commenciez à construire
ce que camus appelait les noces
sanglantes en l'art entre la répression
et le terrorisme